c'est une victoire c'est déjà cette
année c'est une autre huitième édition
donc je suis vraiment très très contente
et très fier à huit ans après malgré
toutes les critiques qui étaient
difficulté d'être encore là donc
j'espère que nous serons là encore pour
de nombreuses années
20e et femmes en uniforme afin de
montrer que les femmes ont du moins ce
qu on a aussi notre place dans la
société
donc quatre tableaux deux belles
surprises donc les filles travaillent
dur elles sont très motivées et elles
seront fin prêtes pour samedi pour pour
le spectacle
d'année en année on arrive à faire
changer les mentalités on arrive à avoir
un peu plus notre place à être un peu
plus accepter les gens parfois ils
prennent pas vraiment conscience de la
réalité de ce qu'ils vivent et à travers
ce concours
il sait cela se démocratiser les gens
comprennent ce que nous vivons les
critiques les insultes donc oui le
le travail paye il ya du changement mais
encore beaucoup de choses à faire que
soit le revenu des services alors les
anciennes miss il y en a pour pas mal
qui sont encore avec nous qui accompagne
aujourd'hui les nouvelles candidates
dans leur aventure
elles transmettent donc ce que le comité
leur apporter durant leur année c'est
maintenant elle près et c'est elle qui
transmettent donc on passe le flambeau
tranquillement et puis sinon les
nomistes partent également à l'élection
nationale pour représenter la martinique
et continue à participer à des
manifestations à des défilés
même si elles ne sont plus lauréate en
titre